if the government has its way
student protests like this could become
a thing of the past
a new bill would ban noise pollution and
political banners in universities
it would also introduce a campus police
empowered to arrest
and charge those considered
troublemakers and disciplinary boards
with power to suspend
or expel students the government says
too much crime goes unpunished on
campuses
where faculty members have been attacked
or bricked into their offices
and students have been raped but these
students
disagree this whole discussion about
insecurity in our universities is not
based in reality
if you look at police statistics the
crimes committed on campuses
are negligible what we're really afraid
of is what's in the bill
the sanctity of university campuses goes
back
to 1973 when the military dictatorship
then ruling greece used the army and
police
to crush a student protest here at the
athens polytechnic
although no one was hurt on campus an
estimated three dozen people were killed
on the night of the operation and the
following days
in 1982 police were forbidden to enter
campuses
but anarchist groups often took
advantage of this to escape arrest
after confrontations with police police
immunity was abused in other ways police
recovered this expansive equipment
stolen by intruders from the athens
polytechnic to be sold on the black
market
when it came to power in 2019 the
conservative
new democracy government allowed police
onto campuses at will
the only thing the government is
achieving is to irritate an already
vexed society and a student body that is
anxious about its future
and it's giving the kiss of life to
extremists specifically the left-wing
syriza opposition
to start a cat-and-mouse game on
university campuses we don't need this
tension
the government decided to tighten campus
security last october
after eight assailants held a university
rector hostage
in his office and called for a return to
immunity from policing
the main problem is created by from
people who come from
outside they are not university students
so
i strongly believe that 90 percent of
the problem is going to be solved
with the introduction of the checking of
the people
who enter the university building
students are protesting against the bill
the government has the votes it needs in
parliament but the students are claiming
the streets
john cerropolos al jazeera athens